[Music]
hey everybody look we're still alive not
even hungover
barely really sleepy i didn't have
i didn't have too hard of a time
actually i went for a ride today too
you did yeah yeah yeah you were you're
out for a while i took the buell out
yeah
[ __ ] had fun it was kind of hot out
there it's gonna be
hot traffic traffic was good yeah it's
sunday not a lot
and it's labor day weekend too so like a
lot of people are off tomorrow so yeah i
guess a lot of people are just kind of
like
i got tired of it though i came back you
got tired
yeah yeah i started getting sleepy again
yeah it's weird like as much as uh as
much as i drank last night we didn't eat
a great deal yesterday
so but i didn't really get all that
[ __ ] up even so after we recorded the
show lesson we did that four hour
[ __ ] show almost four hours on howard
hughes
yeah i was very happy with how that show
turned out i was like wow it was a
four-hour show and i think we talked
about howard hughes for about
90 of the show i think so yeah which is
that's really unlike us i'm so proud of
us we need to do that
we need to do some more paranormal [ __ ]
though we haven't done any paranormal
[ __ ] in a while
well i'm not gonna say like if any if
you guys are patrons you
already know what next week's uh [ __ ] is
gonna be i guess that's sort of
paranormal
i forgot what it was
[Laughter]
the uh we saw we saw a documentary last
night about charles bronson
yeah so it's like so after the show i
was like i was still a little bit drunk
but it wasn't that late it was only like
8 30 or something
so i was like well we should watch
something new uh you know
to review for the matinee on sunday and
i was like i don't know if i can stay
awake for a whole entire movie
yeah but i was going through the new
[ __ ] on to be like the 2020 stuff and i
was like hey look at this there's an
hour-long documentary about charles
bronson which came out this year
let's watch that because it's you know
that's interesting that's
relevant to our interests i liked
bronson bronson was all right you know
what i mean [ __ ]
um kind of what what stood out about him
and they got into
into the documentary is that he had a
good amount of physicality he was
he you know um when i was a kid
i was first introduced to him probably
like something out of like a death wish
[ __ ] two or three you know what i
mean
he was in his 50s 70s i think he was
when he was in his seventies for death
yeah no no because they made five of
those [ __ ] things
yeah i think deathwish five was maybe
the last one that he
he was quite old he didn't get he didn't
get famous in the united in the united
states until he was
about 50. yeah actually
over 50. he probably yeah he was 52 53
yeah
i think when he was in death wish that's
when he became famous
but he had been working in hollywood
since he was real young
uh but he got famous in uh italy
in europe yeah like all over here in
france and stuff yeah and in fact he was
one of the top
draws like around the world and he was
he wasn't unknown in the us for a long
time but he was like kind of seen as
like a
he was just had bit parts he was like
stuff on tv [ __ ] like that
yeah crazy when i was a kid i first saw
him in these [ __ ] crazy death wish
sequels you know they were [ __ ]
ridiculous you know
but they were supposed to be that's
that's that's what they're at that point
death wish was kind of a just an action
joke
you know it was kind of like a chuck
norris movie
yeah they weren't supposed to be
realistic you know and
to me he was just some kind of crazy old
dude you know i didn't realize that
that even at 50 he was almost kind of
like the arnold
schwarzenegger of his time he i didn't
realize he was that because they showed
like a lot of his really early film
roles he played indians a lot because i
guess he was uh lithuanian like his
parents were lithuanian
and he also had a funny voice he had a
funny accent he um
what i when i looked at his wikipedia
page he didn't actually learn to speak
english until he was a teenager yeah
like he spoke lithuanian and russian at
home
yeah and he brought up he was a war
veteran you know he went to uh he went
to world war
ii and that kind of opened his eyes he
came from just a little coal mining town
yeah first yeah and he he grew up rough
you know
um yeah he worked in a coal mine was
starting with ten
but looking at him you know he was an
early bodybuilder
i know i didn't realize that he was that
buff yeah
you know what i mean because they showed
some of his early roles like he'd always
play indians and it's like i was like
wow holy cause so he was always like in
loincloths and stuff
yeah because i guess he looked exotic
and then you know we're talking
this is this is before the golden age of
bodybuilding and arnold schwarzenegger
and and muscle beach of the 70s this is
a long time before by about a decade
yeah and he was in [ __ ] good shape he
had
good muscle definition pretty good mass
he's not a big guy
like i said before people assume that
he's
tall he's not it says right in there
that he was actually short and stocky
yeah but they put him in right boots and
they shot it the right way to make him
look a little bigger than he was
but he's not a big guy i think he might
be an inch taller than me maybe
yeah he was five foot six five foot
seven something okay so about the same
size around my size
but and he was kind of tough they they
said he was
you know if you wronged him you know i
mean
he's the kind of guy who would [ __ ]
hit you he wasn't he wasn't
they said he was difficult to deal with
sometimes on the set because
he was just so [ __ ] gruff with people
and stuff
he was real um introverted yeah and he
didn't like to say a lot although sergio
leone said that he was his favorite
actor to work with
yeah well he was real professional that
was yeah like you know he would kind of
like you know do what even though he was
real quiet
he had a lot of he had a lot of
discipline and if you [ __ ] were
[ __ ] offered he thought you were
taking too long he'd tell you he says
you need her to hurry the [ __ ] up
you know he had a military background so
you know it's just yeah i feel that
you guys need to hurry the [ __ ] up i
ain't gonna be on a set all [ __ ]
that's the way he was you know um
but it was a pretty good it was it was
on tubie right yeah don tooby yeah and
it just came out this year
and like i said it's only 54 minutes
long um
yeah it's like it i didn't know a great
deal i mean i knew that he had done some
acting
prior to death wish because i knew he
was old i didn't realize he was in his
50s when death wish came out and he got
uh famous in the united states
but i didn't realize the extent to which
he was like super well known in europe
and even in asia
like he was easily one of the large like
one of the largest like box office draws
like around the world
except in the us like he was making like
a million bucks a movie
um he kind of went a similar route to
clint eastwood i guess because clint
eastwood kind of
got famous in italian like spaghetti
westerns
um interestingly charles bronson was
offered
several of those roles he was offered
the man with no name
and he turned it down he didn't like the
script dumbass
they even like let him they they asked
him to be in um
for a fistful of dollars they asked you
to be in for a few dollars more and he's
like yeah i don't like it he is
yeah but he came back for for uh what is
it that uh
store what [ __ ] he did he he did that
leonie flick i have it yeah yeah
greatest story ever told no no
once upon a time in the west yeah once
upon a time the greatest story ever told
was that jesus yes
right
yeah i don't know if was he in the one
with the [ __ ] fistful of dynamite was
he in that
i don't remember dynamite yeah you never
first heard the dynamite yeah it was
it was a louis leone flick it was kind
of like fistful of dollars
dollars but it had a dude with a like a
prototype [ __ ]
motorcycle like from the very early oh
okay i know and they had some dynamite
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] never blowing [ __ ]
up
i have to say well you better haven't
seen it since i was a kid my favorite
my favorite bronson movie is one called
uh red sun
where he plays a yeah that was a french
italian yeah that was a really good
italian
no it had japan it was part japanese
yeah it was that too yeah okay i think
it was it was francis
japan yeah okay and he plays a bank
robber
that gets involved with these [ __ ]
samurai that are down
towards the [ __ ] mexican border and
[ __ ] and
uh they lose the imperial sword it was a
gift to the president from the emperor
president united states so
bronson and this samurai a famous
japanese actor he's one of the guys from
[ __ ]
from torah torah torah i don't remember
his name but he was in a lot of stuff
you think he was even in shogun i think
that movie oh yeah the the series yeah i
think he was in that holy [ __ ]
they go out [ __ ] out in the badlands
to try to reclaim get that sword back
and a lot of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] happens
had ursula andrew's hot ass in it
[ __ ] she's uh she did have a hot dog
but i want to get that [ __ ] on blu-ray
red sun that's the one i really
recommend um
dynamite had james coburn in it james
coburn that's right
that's right yeah but um i really
recommend red sun i think that's one of
his best ones
um now the documentary
it did have a part that i didn't really
kind of agree with and they kind of
started to [ __ ] use a bunch of
political buzzwords that i didn't like
like [ __ ] like fascism and [ __ ]
they were [ __ ] talking about [ __ ]
one of the reactionary republicans and
stuff having to do with uh death wish
and then they said well death wish ended
up
in a way destroying his acting career
well he got typecast he got tied cast by
it
and that kind of ended up kind of
destroying his career but you know what
that's a matter of opinion um he was
already old by the time he did death
wish
yeah like i said okay 52 or 53 yeah and
he had been working for a long time in
hollywood and made a lot of successful
movies death wish was a huge
hit he was already starting to age out
though let's be honest okay although and
then he was able to score a bunch of
movies
canon flicks yeah canon uh we worked
with them for a really long time gave
him a [ __ ] ton of money he was one of
their big
one and so then he worked for canon and
for the final
few decades of his life which was much
better
than the average [ __ ] of his age
would have been able to do at that time
yeah so did death wish destroy his
career if you want to look at it from
the point of view of like a [ __ ]
thespian well maybe artistic point of
view
like because he did say that it's like
you know this is the only types of roles
he gets are like vigilante yeah
like well he was just on the wrong side
of the law and [ __ ] like that because of
his rumpled
appearance he looked yeah that was kind
of like the only parts he was given
which i get that that's kind of a bummer
like if you wanted to
yeah he wanted to be more than that but
there's just no way that was going to
happen at his
age and after that [ __ ] movie and the
and the movies that he had
he played in the mechanic as an assassin
and all kinds of stuff
that's the path he was headed yeah he
did a bunch of movies with michael
winner well michael winner did that
but he did a bunch of us i didn't quite
agree with
the statements that that this particular
documentary the way they tried to
characterize it
the way i characterize it is is that he
had an exceptionally long
film life for an action hero
yeah exceptionally long into his 70s
he's making these death wish [ __ ]
movies
all right which is that's up there with
stallone
all right and stallone is one of the
most longest lived action stars
so that's he's like a stallone if you
ask me proto stallone
yeah pronoun proto arnold too
yeah you could say stallone was just as
physical as arnold though
yeah but he's like that like i said i
never realized until they showed some of
his early roles where he was like riding
horses and [ __ ] like that like how
[ __ ] buffy was
yeah that's but that's why he was always
either played an indian
yeah or he played uh like a a criminal
yeah or later on he just always played
atlantis
he made a great he made a great indian
because you could put him in a loincloth
like they did
yeah and he looked [ __ ] great even at
50 running around
basically [ __ ] nude with a damn
loincloth on he had [ __ ] big upper
body and [ __ ] legs and [ __ ]
and he's really jumping around on those
rocks i mean his physicality was
for the era of the 60s exceptional yeah
exceptional and he had such a great face
like
when he was younger too and i think
that's kind of what even i don't
remember if it was sergio leone but um
somebody said the reason that he was so
famous in
europe uh for decades before he was even
like a big star in the united states
was that um in europe they're more
interested they said we're more
interested in character and not faces
whereas like in the us it's more like
what you look like
um but they really loved like his
they said the great thing about him is
that he doesn't have to say anything
like he just has this great presence and
these like eyes it's like he can just
stand there he's like really intense
and it's just like this he just like
exudes this like intensity and a lot of
like filmmakers really really liked that
somebody's asking you to check your
messages it's about bronson but i don't
think we can we're not online well i
will i'll go over
here the uh another thing that was
interesting about the
about the uh documentary is that
um bronson tried some prototype
metrosexuality type [ __ ]
which i didn't know about yeah i didn't
know that in japan
he was uh he he got all this [ __ ]
money
to do these commercials for this [ __ ]
fragrance and men's underarm deodorant
type [ __ ]
and they showed the [ __ ] the
commercial the commercial was awesome he
comes in
and [ __ ] dances around and takes his
shirt off
and looks at himself in the mirror all
macho and putting on his deodorant
and splashing all his [ __ ] fragrance
all over himself
and it's just like i bet that
[ __ ] smells good that's what
you're thinking you know but he's
sure and yeah it's a pretty cool
commercial which i was way ahead of his
time
and then in the movie mechanic
bronson was gonna the way he was gonna
do it is they were gonna make this
the mechanic was about this assassin all
right and this assassin
part of the side story this is is that
he was gay
yeah and that he was in this
relationship
with who was that actor he was a dude
from here wolf wouldn't oh [ __ ] i can't
remember his name
he was quite he was white a bit younger
yeah i can't remember what the famous
he's famous too yeah and they were gonna
have
like a [ __ ] a gay story in the middle
of this [ __ ]
ultra macho story about this [ __ ]
assassin
and it wasn't gonna be like they weren't
gonna portray it as anything [ __ ]
like
i don't know it was just it was just
gonna be something that was just like
[ __ ] for the time pretty [ __ ] out
there yeah you know
but they they edited it from the film
uh so that at least in the us i'm not
sure if they edit it in
in which europe because they were a lot
more tolerant of that
yeah i'd have to say that [ __ ] that
was
for the american audience at that time
the right thing to do is to edit that
out
yeah because everyone would have had
they would they would have went oh [ __ ]
that america
[ __ ] that and then and then they would
have said charles bronson's gay
you know only a gay dude would do that
yeah it would have been like that's what
would have happened
it would have been a bit so i think it
was best because we just have to make a
big thing out of everything
well that's what it would have been back
then back in the 70s this [ __ ] was
[ __ ] white
back in the 70s masculinity had to be
clearly defined
whether you were straight or gay there
wasn't there was no gray
it was black and white it was it was
like an allegiance to an army
you were either a loyalist or a [ __ ]
trader that's the way they looked at it
back then
so i think it was a good thing that they
they edited it out although what would
be interesting
is to if they were to [ __ ] uh sell
that [ __ ] on blu-ray
and have both edits i wonder if that'd
be awesome i'd like to see both edits
i would as well because i'm pretty sure
that like the european version still had
that i don't think it was
super overt i think it was just kind of
like yeah it wasn't any love scenes or
anything they were
just gonna [ __ ] let you know that it
was like a prison type situation that
[ __ ] was so macho that women
were too weak for him
it's like male supremacy yeah i think is
what they were going to go for mark said
every now and then you got to wax your
balls
true um oracle says has anybody
mentioned bronson's twilight zone
episode
yeah yeah we have it but yeah he had
several of them uh he was in one that
was kind of i can't remember which one
it was but yeah he was in one i remember
him being in house of wax
um you know the really old one uh that
was like a small
part dave altman says rush hour with
jackie chan is a remake of red son
i was not aware of that but now i am
yeah thank you
i think that was his best movie somebody
up here mentioned mr majestic i really
like that movie as well
i haven't seen that in a really long
time it was uh two with elizabeth
montgomery your girlfriend
oh yeah my girlfriend her and barbara
eden
they're both my girlfriends me elizabeth
montgomery and barbara eden
see i get the two of those confused
because they look kind of similar yeah
they were different responses for the
same character by two different [ __ ]
uh television uh networks yeah i guess
they saw a dream of a genie and they're
like oh we gotta have a response to that
it's like can we have a genie let's just
have a witch it's kind of similar
yeah maybe that's why i mixed those
those were great those were great shows
uh
i was i liked those shows and like and i
dream of jeannie i used to love
the inside of jeannie's bottle like it
was all like a little bit
pillow her little apartment in there i'm
like man i want a room that looks like i
was just
into that [ __ ] outfit this year
i was like even even as a kid i'm just
[ __ ] just sitting there
drooling like what's in the booth look
at that cleavage like
i wish that was pulled down just a
little bit further and then it had that
screen
they had to give her a special belt to
cover up her belly button because they
couldn't show any belly buttons on the
[ __ ] network isn't that crazy
every everybody's got belly buttons they
had some kind of a [ __ ] thing
if the if you could see the belly button
the pants were too low so they had a
[ __ ] special belt that went around it
that went up
it covered it
they didn't like you that hip hugger
action they thought that she was a seat
this [ __ ] was too dirty
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] man i was when i was
uh when i was a little kid
probably eight nine ten something like
that i had a i
i dressed up like janie for halloween my
mom made it yeah it was super pretty
yeah i had little i had the little top
and the lips she made me some little
pants that were all like [ __ ]
net and everything yeah it was nice both
of those shows were good though
yeah of course i'm gonna go watch them
now and they're probably like
they're probably corny now well i'm sure
they're corny they were corny then
yeah but they're for them dr bombay they
call it doctor mommy
they might be fun to watch like one
night when we're like really [ __ ] hey
every gay dude from los angeles was in
her family [ __ ] coming back from the
remember that all the warlocks were
basically gay
dr bombay well yeah he wasn't really gay
but
he kind of seemed like it but then
definitely uncle arthur
yeah yeah that was so what's his name
[ __ ] that dude he was awesome
one from hollywood squares poland
pauline that's right i love paul
you want to get paul andrews there
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] hilarious if he'd be
drunk on the hollywood squares [ __ ]
saying all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and they and they would [ __ ] have
they couldn't censor it very well back
then it would
make it through yeah well yeah because
like i said i think live shows were on a
delay but it wasn't very long
it was only like a couple of seconds you
had to be really quick on like
he'd say some crazy [ __ ] and it would
slip out it would slip through
yeah i mean because he had to kind of be
kind of clever to understand what he
said
it might take a few minutes for it to
sink in that he was talking about giving
head or
we'll see is that he could say stuff
in such a way that it didn't sound dirty
until you thought about it
that it was too late yeah and then the
[ __ ] audience would be
[ __ ] just busting up man 70s was a
good time
it was a real good time everything was
like innuendo yeah it was all in you
went you remember that [ __ ]
and they were a lot wilder and they were
there was no such thing as political
correctness they
didn't give a [ __ ] what was that game
show that where they had couples on
there and they asked what the [ __ ] the
newlywed game the newlyweds yeah
they said all kinds of questions every
single one of those questions was a
sexual idea yeah
yeah uh dominic asked did you guys
finish off the stand
we did we finished watching it that was
like so much better than i remembered
yeah it looked a lot better than i than
it looked uh the copy that i saw yeah
because like i said we just kind of saw
the [ __ ] tv that was like like i said
next time we'll have to watch uh
i want his red because i want to see
that again i want to see the tv the tv
version of uh the shiny the shining now
yeah
i can't remember where we watched that
because we watched it
probably three or four years ago and i
remember because we sat like uh we
stayed up all night and watched it like
in one go
but i can't remember where we saw it at
i'd buy it actually yeah i liked it
enough you didn't like it i don't look i
don't love it
um i just feel like it's terrible it's
just i
i just i bet you a good blu-ray edition
that you they could probably clean that
thing up and it'd probably look a lot
better
i don't know if they clean it up too
much it might look even shittier because
like the makeup on the
ghosts and stuff like that was really
nice they can work wonders with
uh [ __ ] some of this digital stuff
they could change the time i mean you'd
really have
to like make it look a lot better well
you got to remember
we saw it on the television crtv format
yeah and you could reformat that for
digital and [ __ ] and do
you do all kinds of computer
enhancements and probably get that thing
to look really good
yeah probably because look how much
better the stand looked
i saw the other version of the stand
that was the television version
for crt and it looked like [ __ ] on
youtube yeah
this looked a lot better it did like i
said they did some work on that
surprise it looked like a movie kind of
the stand remake is coming out
december 17th 2020. we'll see how that
is
and like i said i think i mentioned this
on the show last night just kind of
apropos
nothing but uh netflix is doing haunting
a blind manor
the second season of haunting of hill
house except this is based on turn of
the screw
that's coming out october 9th i saw the
trailer and it looks really good
i just saw the trailer like yesterday so
i'm very very very excited about it
so uh yeah i this is this is a free
documentary on 2b like i said it's only
54 minutes long
um i found out a whole bunch of stuff
that i didn't know about
charles bronson it was actually really
interesting now they didn't mention they
mentioned that he'd grown up poor and
that his parents were lithuanian and
stuff
um but they didn't mention i looked up
on wikipedia like i said they didn't
mention that he had
had to work in a coal mine from when he
was 10 years old
because his family were so poor they had
like 15 kids or something
deborah's talking about how it was crazy
how great barbara eden looked without
any plastic surgery
i kind of i kind of suspect she she
wasn't fully natural
people don't yeah i think people got it
back then but it wasn't people weren't
open about it yeah they like you
kept it secret that that looks like a
nose job
they are the bridge of her nose that's
very rare and that has the indentation
yeah yeah yeah disney loves that you
know they recruit all the disney
princess girls you have to have that
profile if you don't have it
you know unless you're one of the like
[ __ ] uh like you know
one of the more ethnic characters you
know like the [ __ ] indian girls and
you know what was her name what was the
indian princess
pocahontas
but if you're if you're a caucasian
cartoon character
you have to have that [ __ ] look that
barbara eden had and it's this weird
they they even have the ratio numbered
that she told me what it was there's
this [ __ ] ratio that they have to do
for forehead
to indentation and then the length of
the nose there's a
another because you have to look as much
like the cartoon
counterpart as possible possible and
barbara eden her profile is is that
disney cartoon profile
yeah that's what that is and which could
be natural but
a lot of times it isn't i don't yeah i
don't see too many people who look like
that
yeah and i'm pretty sure pretty sure
um barbara eden had silicone implants
back in those days though they didn't
they didn't always do it by putting an
implant in and filling it up with
silicone a lot of times it was something
called infusion
they just take a damn iv bag with
silicone in it and stick a damn needle
right into your [ __ ]
tent and just let that [ __ ] fill up yeah
we talked about that on the show
last night and and
we talked i was talking about the
controversy behind silicone infusion
in south america it's still very common
to this day and a lot of surgeons think
that that's
actually the best way to do it um you
just have to be careful that
it has to be completely sterile
medical grade silicone um or
if it's industrial grade silicone it's
very cheap and it's been stored in
[ __ ] dirty containers
and you could get a real bad infections
it could it could theoretically kill you
well yeah because you don't know what
the hell you're injecting it's not
really sure
you don't know how pure it is and you
don't know where it's been
uh although you know these are street
girls that doing this they'll [ __ ]
take the [ __ ] and put it in a clean pot
and heat it up to about 400 degrees and
try to kill all the bacteria
just boiling it doesn't really boil it
just gets hot you know
and then they [ __ ] try to filter it
and hope that there isn't any kind of
industrial solvents in there
there's it's risky to do it that way
yeah but the difference in medical grade
silicone
and and uh service grade silicone is
about a thousand times in other words
you know what i mean [ __ ]
a gallon of [ __ ] industrial silicones
[ __ ] 50 cents
yeah versus 500 you know for medical
[ __ ] so
you know these are girls down the favela
trying to do this [ __ ] but
that's enough of the [ __ ] silicone
implant yeah dominic did i notice all
the horror film director cameos in the
stand i did indeed
uh tom was like not he's like who the
[ __ ] was that i'm like hey look it's
john landis hey yeah
these people are mcgarris well he's mick
garris directed it anyway
but yeah there was uh i think sam raimi
was in there too somewhere i recognized
him yeah he was in there
like he was just in one scene like in a
diner or something like that but yeah i
did see that i thought that was kind of
cool that they stuck all that i had
completely forgotten that that was in
there
so uh yeah tammy says excuse me while i
go boil my boobs
all right so i guess we've talked enough
about that um
probably we'll be back streaming
tomorrow probably be another
new movie if i can find another one
worth watching uh
so thanks everybody for dropping by and
we'll talk to you guys again tomorrow